videoconferencing is getting more and
more popular every single day especially
during the covert 19 pandemic so today
we're going to be looking at Microsoft
teams and comparing it to WebEx
what's going on guys my name is David
Tommy and welcome back to the channel if
you're new here thank you so much for
joining me on this channel we talk about
technology and everything related to the
topic if that's something that interests
you make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:20 style we're almost that 2,000
subscriber mark so it made a lot if you
did today we're focusing on two very
powerful platforms WebEx and Microsoft
teams I've compared these to Skype and
zoom and things like that in the past
but in reality it isn't fair to compare
these two platforms to any of those
others why because it's like comparing
apples and oranges Microsoft teams and
WebEx are both very unique very powerful
platforms they're designed with big
companies in mind but also can cater to
smaller guys if you need something that
can do a lot more than just video
conferencing these are the two platforms
you want to be looking at both these
platforms have a free and a paid version
the free version for most users and most
companies will be more than enough to
get you through a lifetime of use the
paid version of the other hand is
something that is worth considering if
you're looking at investing and doing
more and more video conferencing in the
near future
if you've used video conferencing in any
way shape or form in the past be it
Skype Microsoft teams zoom WebEx
whatever it might be you're very well
aware of the simple fact of video
calling in 2020 it's very easy to start
a video call with somebody without
having to know too much about technology
both of these platforms allow you to
share your screen share some files have
a library of these files so you can
access them very quickly use a
whiteboard draw and share documentation
in real time
Microsoft teams has the advantage of
being a Microsoft product so you can
integrate real-time Word and Excel
PowerPoint documents and actually have
all the team collaborate on the same
document at the same time both of these
platforms stream in 1080p which means
high definition video calling for all of
your video needs if you're looking at
up to 25 people in one space and have a
mass teleconference you can do this on
WebEx if you only need 20 people this is
where Microsoft team tops out if you're
looking at doing web hosting or
webcasting or a webinar then both of
these have some great advantages
Microsoft teams you can do a webinar to
up to 10,000 people watching your
livestream but unfortunately after 250
people Microsoft teams drops the quality
from 1080p down to 720p and then
continues to go down as the numbers
increase WebEx on the other hand can
have up to a hundred thousand people on
the same video conference you heard me
correctly 100 thousand people now I
don't know a hundred thousand people you
probably don't know 100 thousand people
but if you work in a large company
that's multinational there's a good
chance there's more than a hundred
thousand people employed in your company
and this is where this platform really
thrives just like Microsoft teams the HD
quality does start to drop out but it
drops out after 3,000 people have joined
so you have significantly more numbers
at 1080p with WebEx versus Microsoft
teams during this pandemic of the covert
19 crisis both platforms are
continuously updating their software
making it better and trying to get you
to use their software so recently WebEx
has given you a whole bunch of more free
stuff for example instead of maxing out
at 50 people on a teleconference on a
free webinar you can actually max out at
a hundred people now and unlike zoom for
example which gives you a 40 minute
limited time frame during a video
conference WebEx now offers unlimited
for free both of these platforms go
above and beyond video conferencing and
if you're considering them you're
considering them to be a scheduler a
task manager an office administrator
everything that they can be and they
should be both Microsoft teams and WebEx
offer you a direct integration to your
cloud services your email services and a
million and one
other integrated apps directly into the
software Microsoft teams does have a
plethora of more integratable apps into
the software so if you're looking to
integrate more things than just your
basics onedrive Google Drive things like
that Microsoft teams has a much higher
chance of having the integration already
ready for you in a single click of a
button
so what can you really do on both of
these platforms well you can chat
directly an instant message anybody in
your company or anybody using the
software you can video call them
obviously you can share and schedule
meetings directly in the software and
integrate it directly into your calendar
which is a great bonus if you're a busy
person with both of these platforms you
can call people from anywhere in the
world on their personal mobile number so
both of these offer a cloud calling
solution yes this is above and beyond
paid feature that you actually have to
go out and investigate into what your
company requires but it does offer you a
solution that really allows you to step
away from the current mobile phone
providers and the telcos in your country
the United States of America has much
better infrastructure already built in
for this cloud calling whereas Australia
is lacking behind a little bit but we
are getting there very slowly but if the
platform's offer very good security but
only WebEx offers you end-to-end
encryption as an optional addition now I
have to stress this because from the
start
WebEx is encrypted to be in transit and
at rest just like Microsoft teams is
which is a very good encryption rate the
chances of your data being hacked whilst
it's already at the servers of Microsoft
or WebEx is very limited but it does
mean in some way shape or form
regardless if they say they can't or not
somebody can access your data in between
so what about I really told you here
I've told you that both platforms do
really really well both platforms are
able to perform at the absolute peak for
majority of your services that you can
need but what I haven't told you is that
Microsoft teams has a little bit of an
edge here
Microsoft teams has allowed you to
simply integrate other apps directly
into their platform so for example their
desktop app allows you to integrate
WebEx directly in to the software so if
you're using Microsoft teams and your
colleague is using WebEx or vice-versa
you or they can simply click on the
integration app button at the top the
little plus symbol add WebEx and then
all the sudden you can start join
schedule do anything on a WebEx meeting
that synchronizes with all their data
you can also do this with zoom if that's
something that you're looking for for
cross compatibility with everybody using
a different video conferencing tool and
a different video conferencing platform
Microsoft teams allows you to use that
simplified version that all in one
platform having said all that to my
current knowledge
it only implements with zoom and WebEx
at the current time in the future it
might integrate with every other
platform out there but so far it's just
these two I personally think Microsoft
teams also tips the edge a little bit
just by being a Microsoft product it has
the flexibility and capability to
integrate with Word and office 365 and
all the other software that they offer
seamlessly and it gives you that live
direct collaboration on the video
conference so my final conclusion and my
final thoughts is they're both fantastic
platforms that will do incredible jobs
regardless of which one you pick but
Microsoft teams takes the crown for me
ever so slightly that's all for me today
guys thank you so much for joining me I
hope you enjoyed the video if you did
make sure you smash that subscribe
button
20:20 style and as always I'll see you
next Monday